so this is Magnus is going to do a game
against minus 12 but I yeah I played a
blitz tournament yesterday and after
that I'm not feeling so brave so let's
go with 11 and yeah that was wrong so
aha here it is
so we have a new feature which you can
now choose the pieces and the board that
you want to use different different sets
different boards different colors so
it's more of a choice than the West beer
before so let's see I think I might go
with something really funky today and go
with this hope that not that's not too
much of an eyesore for all you guys
watching so - place one night s3c for I
guess I played a lot of different
openings even back then I'll just play
something solid today I really don't
know what mine is 11 knows about the
Queen's Gambit let's try and find out
Queen c2 that was a surprise now we try
after a 6 C 5 yeah I think I should be
doing fine here in general
but we'll see what happens let h7 Wow to
make this slightly awkward move I think
that blacks should be doing all right
oops there I almost blundered pretty
badly
I think my position should be nice but
we'll see what happens so now I was
threatening to drop his bishop where
which is why he decided to chop it off
but it seems that I have a pretty nice
advantage with oops I think you might
have language right there now I have a
piece for a couple of phones those
phones might be strong eventually but
there's no way that he has enough
compensation Magnus we have a question
from unrated ash asking I'm 13 years old
and rated 1305 can I go further what do
you think well first of all having the
same rating as your age it's not too bad
so if you'll get to 2,000 by the time
you're 20 then it should be should be
happy
no seriously speaking I think as long as
you as you have an interest as long as
it's fun um you can you can go far let
me just concentrate for a minute just
not to get mated here so now chop off
the Queen's and and so yeah I think if
you want to be world champion it's maybe
a bit bit late not not because you
cannot get to that strength but because
I don't intend to give up my crown no
time soon but
let me see
no I'll try now I won't why am I
thinking I have and so much material
it's so hard to to to think and talk at
the same time I really wouldn't like
recommend that so so with that in mind
let's ask you another question
DJ 86 asks what is the most important
thing to improve for a 2150 ehlo player
to get to 2300 to 2400 tactics or
strategy um right now uh one of the
things that separates the best players
from the second best is the ability to
see little combinations and that's one
I'm going to do right now a little
combination to force a new nuclear and
then the game is completely over but I
think the difference between 2150 and
2300 isn't really that big so with just
steady steady dose of playing solving
tactics start and just in general
analyzing your games then it should be
should be able to to to get there I
think at least that was the case for me
just
it will take some take some time but I
think if you've gotten to 2150 you
and you can get to 22300 so the game was
over the game is over already
that was pretty quick all I have to say
yeah let's try try another one just
since this was so quick not online phew
that was a close race but you pulled it
off with you in the end it wasn't it
wasn't very close this must be a bargain
the app does this wasn't fortunately it
wasn't very close what age are you going
to take um yeah let's try twelve before
you get in there what techniques did you
use to train yourself to visual
visualize 10 to 20 moves ahead
besides solving tactics I don't know I
started out pretty early reading chess
books going through chess games in my
head and then when you do that it's very
good training for visualizing the the
board because you have to be able to see
from one diagram to to the to the other
I'm sure - 12 didn't know this stuff I
mean this is absolute nonsense like
there's just no way no way oh but I
don't know this stuff either that's the
that's the - gotta say - 24 he does not
know his his this exchange coin fault
I don't know what to do here I'm Rick
I'm heavily regretting my choice of
opening and I'm also very suspicious
about -12 I don't think he's supposed to
know this
weren't you in Grand Master my 13 you
should have known national how what do
you know
Touche so speaking of not being okay
with your opening what's the best way to
study the opening and do you recommend
studying previous games by masters or
just another way
it's from Roth in new 9900 I'm getting
mated already I hate just getting
absolutely massacred why did I so what
was the question again something let's
go back to the question about the
opening what's the best way to study the
opening for study previous games or
another way well studying previous games
typical games analyzing with the
computer I mean these are the general
ideas I guess if you could play any
chess player in history who would it be
it's from the real Jay Andelman oh [ __ ]
I'm getting absolutely my secret just
you can always use a hint um
I mean I can't even take that does this
work
yeah it works he's meeting me so if I
take Fe Bishop's III Quincy to a 95 to
93 and let's meet okay
Knight b6 back I regard that as my first
minor success and again let's come back
to the question if you could play any
chess player in here ah yes probably
probably a couple Blanca or Fischer time
for a self-check
I wholeheartedly agree with that so the
game goes on but it feels like I'm
fighting a lost cause here if you
weren't a professional chess player what
career do you think you have I don't
know I'm glad I don't have to find out
okay didn't you blunder now okay so if I
go overseas you guys will be fine this
damned tactical monster to our Cohens
asking about the first chess book if you
go into Magnus age five in the app and
you go and read the story under it it'll
tell you the first chess book or it
might be age six
trying desperately to tricking efore
does this work efore just king a Jetta
it's really hard to define tricks when
that when the position is lost now
finally I get a four okay rook teacher
[ __ ] dude um you're asking about the
skin if you go into the game options in
the top right hand side you're going to
choose boards and pieces so you can also
select different pieces and different
boards and you can use your brain power
to change them up okay so if I take yes
rook f6
that's clever um six anyway
RBG 425 just the wrong square for my
king Magnus the question from spotless
eternal asking when was the last time
your sister or dad beat you at chess
um it's well I mean we don't actually
play too much chess hey I lost in in our
family anymore
so it seems like you would need to work
on these chess skills
let's try again nah I don't want to try
again no we don't play too too much
chess anymore we talk about chess and
chess things but we don't actually play
too much chess among each other
all right thank
there is one other question how do you
feel when you play against a high rated
player when you weren't that high rated
and what preparations did you do for
that oh it feels like playing minus
twelve just feels I just feel absolutely
helpless no actually when I was little
and played high rated players sometimes
I was a little bit timid and I would
over estimate my opponents a bit and
sometimes agreed to to draw us in
positions that were better for me but I
think to some extent your appetizer Oh
tight gross with the meal so as you as
you get better you start to understand
that these opponents aren't actually as
strong as you as you thought they were
and so in general your opponent's are
human they make mistakes so don't
overestimate them too much but of course
have respect for filet skills and maybe
two more questions do you think there
are any players who aren't playing at
the moment who could challenge you wanna
come back um no no maybe out the way I'm
playing today but not not that top low
what's your number one tip for improving
chess that's that's the most obvious one
play on the play line is that and with
that will say thanks and sign off